Hello, welcome to my talk on the seven
habits of highly effective generative AI
evaluations. I'm Justin Mohler. I'm a
principal applied AI architect at AWS. I
have degrees in physics, math, law, and
business. I've been working in natural
language processing for about 15 years
on and off and generative AI for the
last four years uh inside of AWS. My
team is a small specialist team that
helps customers scale Genai workloads.
So I've had the opportunity to work on
many many workloads across all different
industries, all different sizes of
customers. Some small workloads, some of
the largest in North America. Um, I'll
also mention that because of that
experience, I've seen a lot of workloads
fail and I've seen a lot of workloads
succeed. And so, one of the things my
team does now is that we've gathered up
a lot of the best practices we've seen
across the successful workloads as well
as some of the common failure points
we've seen on the failed workloads and
share them as best practices in talks
like this
one. All right, so let's get going. The
first question is uh what is the biggest
challenge in scaling generative AI? You
may you may be able to guess the
solution here as this is what the talk's
all about. Um, but I I would argue that
it's
evaluations. I in in my experience,
having been called in to help many
different customers scale their Geni
workloads, there's lots of concerns that
come up. And when I ask this question
with a live audience, there's things
like cost,
hallucinations, accuracy,
capacity, all these different types of
um concerns come up. But the number one
thing that I see across all workloads is
a lack of evaluations. And in
particular, I call it the missing piece
to scaling geni because a lot of times
when a customer has
uh successfully built a a PC and they
have a a workload that they like or
chatbot that seems cool and they're
figuring out how to scale it, um this is
the piece that I come in and most often
it's missing. And when we add
evaluations, it unlocks the ability to
scale. and we're going to look at how
that
happens, but it's by far the most common
way to unlock scale. All right, I'll
give you a quick customer example. Um,
in uh July 2024, I was called in to as a
as like an escalation on a workload
where a customer was doing document
processing and they'd been working on
this document processing workload for
about I think six months, 12 months
maybe. Um, and they had six or eight
engineers working on it. So, it was a
pretty big project at that point. and
the uh the
the VP of technology that was in charge
of the project called me in. He asked
everyone else to leave the room and he
was like, "Look, this project, we spent
a bunch of money on it. Accuracy is at
22%. We're thinking about just cutting
the project. We're not getting the
results we need. So, I need you to tell
me if we can save this thing." And uh
essentially, I spent a couple of weeks
doing discovery and understanding what
was going on in the workload. And the
number one thing that I realized was
they had zero evaluations, right? They
had this big process and end to end they
had a single number coming out the end
that said, "Well, it's 22% accurate." So
what I did is design a evaluations
framework and the results were almost
funny because once the evaluation
framework was in place and you could see
exactly where the problems were, fixing
them were trivial, right? Fixing the
problems wasn't really the challenge.
Increasing accuracy wasn't really the
challenge. It was knowing where the
problems were and what was causing them.
So over the course of the next six
months they built the evaluation
framework. They fixed uh many of the
issues that came up. They were able to
achieve 92% accuracy by January. Uh when
uh which 90% was their threshold for
launching to production at scale and
they launched and became the single
largest document processing workload uh
on AWS in North America at the
time. All right. So evaluations are
really really important. what are they?
How do we actually build these things?
This is the place I like to start with
evaluations because many times,
especially if you're coming from a
traditional a IML back uh background,
you look at evaluations as a way to
measure
quality because you're you're familiar
with things like well what's your F1
score? What's your precision and recall?
And you get a score and it just tells
you how well you're doing. And while uh
Jenny or Triv AI evaluations do produce
a score, if anything, it's a it's a far
third of the top reasons why we do
evaluations with geni
workloads. The main goal with any
evaluation framework should be to
discover problems. Similar to the
workload example that I just shared, if
your evaluation framework tells you
where the problems are and perhaps even
suggests solutions because it includes
an element of generative AI reasoning,
now we can improve our workloads. And of
course, yes, we need to measure quality.
That's very important. But I I start
this way because when you think about
designing an evaluation framework, if
you come in with the mindset that it's
going to find errors, you design it in a
very different way than if you come in
and with the mindset that it's just
going to measure how well you're doing.
All right. So, let's double click on
what that looks like.
Um and and before we do that though, I
do want to I I do want to add a second
aside on why I think evaluations are so
po
important.
Um my team within AWS is a very small
specialist team and so we have to have
very very strict filters on which
projects we say yes to and which ones we
support. And my experience has been
evaluations are the number one filter
that separates a science project from a
successful project. When I talk to a
team and the team says, "Can you teach
me about multi-agent collaboration?" And
I say, "Great. Let's sit down and spend
two hours putting together a gold
standard set for our evaluations so that
your multi- aent collaboration framework
project is successful." If the team
comes back and says, "Oh gosh, two hours
on eval sounds boring. Can you just give
me the toys to play with?" I I know
right away that's a science project and
it's not going to go anywhere. and and
science projects are important. They're
a fun way to learn. They're just not
what goes to scale. On the other hand,
for my projects that have been wildly
successful, where customers have had
100x return on investment or maybe cut
their cost by 10,000% or something like
that, those customers when I say, hey,
can we spend two hours uh building an
eval framework? They say, why don't we
send spend four? Right? Evals are so
important and we recognize that and this
project is so important that we're going
to invest the time. So I I'll as an
aside I'll just mention it as my number
one filter for deciding which projects
are going to be successful and which are
worth spending time on.
All right. So,
evalative AI world come with baggage,
right? And especially if you have a
traditional AIML background, it can be a
little scary, right? You you look at
evals and it's free text coming out and
you're like, "Oh my gosh, it's not going
to be a specific number. I can't
mathematically calculate an exact number
every time. Let's
panic." Right? And it turns out that the
human race has been grading and
evaluating
uh free text workloads for uh hundreds
of years if not thousands, right? Um can
you imagine if my professor in English
assigns me an essay and says uh write me
a three-page essay on the on the
emotional meaning of
sunshine. And I I spend an I spend my
hours and I write my essay. I turn it
in. The professor says, "Well, I can't
calculate an exact answer to this. I
can't calculate your exact source, so I
give up. I'm just not going to score
it." No, of course not. The professor is
going to give it a score. And we can
evaluate generative AI in the same way
that we've been evaluating free text for
for decades and generations, right? But
the key understanding is if you have a
bad professor, they just give you a
score. Maybe you've had this experience
like me. You've turned in an essay and
got an F, right? If you just get a
score, you're like, "Well, that that
stinks, but what do I do with it?"
Right? With generative AI, we can go a
bit deeper. We can do what the good
professors do, which is point out what
you did wrong, point out where you can
improve, right? This is why evaluations
in the term in the in the context of
grade school are very very valuable
because you can improve. This is the
same for generative AI.
All
right, let me give you another example,
another um unique complexity to the
evaluation of generative AI. This is a
2x4 and I gave myself the task of
drilling a 1-in hole into the 2x4 all
the way through it. And when I talk to a
live audience, I ask for a thumbs up,
thumbs down. How did I do on this task?
Right? Very similar to the types of
feedback we often have for generative AI
uh workloads. And often I get mostly
thumbs up. There's always that one guy
that gives me a thumbs down. Um, and
what you're done, what you've done is
evaluated my output. But if the
methodology I used to to create this
hole looks like
this, right? Suddenly maybe I didn't do
such a good job. Maybe how I got there
matters. And the reason is even though I
managed to make a good hole this time,
if this is my setup, if this is the
methodology I used to to achieve it or
in the context of generative AI, if this
is the reasoning I took to create the
hole, then maybe I need to I need to
rethink my system. So let me give you
another example in the context of a real
customer use case. This is a meteorology
company that was creating um summaries
of local weather based on sensor data.
So, I've summarized what their prompt
looked just so it's easy to read here.
But essentially, they have a prompt that
gives sensor data like it's raining and
it's 40° and it's windy and it's asking
for a
summary. And if the summary says uh
today it's sunny and bright outside. All
of the sudden it's like hm something has
gone wrong, right? If we evaluate this,
the score is zero. You know, this prompt
gets an F, but we don't know why, right?
But what if we ask the model to explain
its reasoning? And this reasoning is
it's important to mental health to be
happy. So I decided not to talk about
the rain. Now that we've looked behind
the scenes and we've seen kind of what
the model how the model got there, we
suddenly have a lot more insight into
how to fix the problem. Right? And you
can imagine this in the context and why
this is such a big problem in the
context of evals. Let's look at the at
the opposite opposite example. If we
give it data and it says it's sunny and
then the response comes out in sunny.
Well, we'll say response is 10 out of
10. Awesome. I've built a a brilliant
prompt and I can go to scale. And this
is a danger because what happens is if
you didn't eval the reasoning and this
was the
reasoning. All of a sudden you're like,
okay, maybe my prompt isn't working
right because even though I got the
right answer, I drilled the hole
correctly in this one case, right? The
reasoning is is uh not getting me where
I need to
be. Okay.
The last um the last step before I get
into my my seven habits of generative AI
uh evaluations is what I call prompt
decomposition. And although this uh this
technique is not specific to
evaluations, it's often done in the
context of evaluations because when it
comes to geni, you only can attach an
eval to one prompt. It's difficult to
evaluate the first half of a prompt
versus the second half of of a prompt,
right? I think of it like a multimeter
for my electrical engineers out there.
You've got your two sensors. You put one
sensor at the beginning of a prompt, one
sensor at the end of the prompt, and
you're sensing what went on in the whole
prompt. Many times, if the prompt is
very large and it does a lot of
complicated things, it's difficult to
understand where the error is because
you just kind of get like, well, there's
something going wrong in this big pile
of code or big pile of prompting. And
so, um, this is that same weather
company. This is an example from them
where they were having to write a
summary of today's weather. Inside their
prompt, they did a lot of different
instructions based on what the sensor
data was. And one of the things they
noticed is that for a portion of their
prompt, they actually had it say, okay,
well, if the wind speed is like less
than five, then it's not very windy, but
if it's more than five, then it's windy.
And what was happening is in a in the in
the PC stage, that worked great. when
they tried to scale out maybe two to
three% of the time Claude was coming
back and saying oh uh the wind speed is
seven seven is less than five so it's
not windy right and just completely
messing up the
math so what we did here is a series of
prompt decompositions and if you're
interested in it I've got a blog here
you can check out
um
the basic idea is take the big prompt
and break it into a a chaining series of
prompts from From an eval standpoint,
that means that you can attach eval to
each section of the prompt. And what
that allows you to do is decide, okay,
well, this section is working great.
This section isn't. So now I know where
to focus my efforts. The other thing it
does is allows you to decide, is
generative AI even the right tool for
that section of the prompt. Right? So in
the case of this weather prompt, um,
doing a mathematical comparison, is
seven larger than five? You don't need
genai for that. Python is perfect at
that. It gets it accurate, perfectly
accurate. And so in this series of
chaining steps, one step was a Python
mathematical comparison. When they made
this change, the accuracy went to
100%. And they could tell the accuracy
of each step. All
right, I will briefly mention as well in
the context of that uh prompt
decomposition. It's a very very common
pattern and so I wanted to talk about
its impact on evaluations. One of the
most common patterns we see is semantic
routing. some kind of query comes in or
an input to a workload. And the first
step is well, what kind of task is this?
If it's a it's an easy task, go to a
small model. If it's a hard task, go to
a large model. And by doing this, um,
what I'm doing is using the right model
for the job. Not dependent on the prompt
itself, but depending on the input from
the user and the complicatedness, the
complication level of the task from the
user. And the interesting piece here is
again attaching evals to each step. And
so that means for for an eval semantic
router often the input that you're
evaluating as a query and the output is
just the number one or the number two in
this case. And what you'll see when you
run the eval is often even breaking this
down significantly increases your
accuracy because you're removing what I
call dead space or dead tokens. Right?
If this was all one big prompt, what
you'd see is your instructions, your
instructions for your easy stuff, your
instructions for your hard stuff, right?
And if an easy query comes in, it only
needed those easy instructions. Those
hard instructions are basically dead
space. They weren't necessary, but what
they are is extra cost and an
opportunity for the model to get
confused. So often by breaking it down
this way, we see we see the evaluation
showing the accuracy popping up because
you're only sending the necessary
information for the
task. All right, so let's jump into the
good stuff. I I didn't mean to keep you
waiting, but here we are. These are the
seven most common trends I see across
all generative AI uh workloads that have
successfully scaled. I will say I have
never seen a workload go to scale
without evaluations and most of them
also include these seven habits. The
first one is
fast. It is the case that I have seen
evaluations built with the mindset that
getting results within a week is
okay. What happens is I I make a prompt,
I push it to some kind of test site, I
email a team to go test it, they test it
whenever they feel like, they email me
back whenever they feel like, and a week
later I get to make one more change to
my prompt. And you can imagine a team
that's working on that mindset that they
get to have like four changes or eight
changes a month versus a team that's
managed to build an evaluation framework
that operates in seconds and they can
make hundreds of changes every day and
hundreds of tests every day. Right? The
pace of innovation, the pace of
increasing your accuracy is going to be
much much faster. Uh to the point where
I don't think I've ever seen a workload
scale unless it's gone through many many
iterations. And so sometimes just
knowing that at the outset is helpful
for teams.
um rather than somehow you're going to
craft this beautiful perfect prompt your
first try and never change it again. Uh
I will say and this is what we're going
to see a example of in in just a minute.
Um often my my rule of thumb target is
30 seconds to run your evaluation
framework. And you do that by using
generative AI as a judge to evaluate or
if the if the output's numeric like from
a semantic router where it's one two
three you're using Python to say is this
did it output a one? Yes or no? Is one
equal one? Yes. Okay. Good job.
Um, the reason I say 30 seconds is often
what it means is you spend 10 seconds in
parallel sending a 100 test cases for
generation. I've created a test. I've
created a prompt template I want to
test. I run it across my 100 test cases
and get results. 10 seconds. Then I take
those results and inund more parallel
calls I judge them. So I take my
results, compare them against my gold
standard and I and I get a 100 judges
going per 10 seconds. And in the final
10 seconds, I take my output from my 100
judges and I summarize it. Often that
means breaking it down by categories and
by what's right and what's wrong. And so
what I see in my output is not 100
generated out responses that now I have
to go read through and figure junk out.
What I see in that last 10 seconds is a
summary where it says, "Hey, you know
what? For all of your questions, all of
your queries that had to do with taxes,
when you got it right, here's what the
trends were. When you got it wrong,
here's what the trends were." And again,
it's going from that p from that mindset
of how do I figure out what's going
wrong and where the errors are and how
to fix
them. Quantifiable is my second one. All
all effective frameworks also produce
numbers, right? And I sometimes
depending on the teams, I get a lot of
push back on this because you're right
that they're not always the exact same
number every time you run the test,
right? If I turn in an essay, maybe I
turn it in on Thursday and I get a score
or I turn it in on Friday. Friday, my
professor has a few cups of uh glasses
of wine before grading and so my score
is a little better. Right? This happens
in real life. It happens with AI vals.
The way that we deal with it is the same
in real life as it is with eval which is
we we make it numerous. Right? Even if
one if there's a little bit of jitter in
the score in the quantifiable score that
we ask for uh if we have enough test
cases and we average across those test
cases that jitter goes out just like in
grade school hopefully you didn't turn
in one assignment ever. Uh you turn in a
bunch of assignments and your your final
score was the average of all of
those. The other reason why numerous is
so important is that we want to cover
all of our we want to be diverse and
cover all of our uh test cases. Uh
right? So um oftent times when I'm
running this as an exercise with
customers even the the the exercise of
building 100 test cases is very valuable
for the team to figure out what the
scope of the project is because
inevitably someone will say hey when
someone asks about taxes we can we can
direct them to this site where they can
get their W TWS and then someone else
will say no no no if they ask about
taxes we can't respond at all because
we're not allowed to right and the team
is debating the product design nothing
to do with geni but it's a good exercise
to understand what is the scope of what
you want to answer and and make sure you
have questions outside of what you want
to answer so that you can you can
measure that the that the model is is uh
redirecting those that are outside of
scope. The next habit is explainable.
This is that insight where it's like
don't just look at the outputs, look at
how you got there, right? Look at how
the model is reasoning and in
particularly I I said reasoning for
generation and scoring. Look at how your
judge is reasoning as well for for in in
some cases where you're asking the judge
to do a lot of reasoning because just
like you're doing prompt engineering for
your for your for your prompt for your
users, you also need to engineer the the
judge prompt and make sure the judge is
is scoring correctly. Um I'll I'll show
a small example of that in just a
minute. But the general idea is just
like a a professor grading a paper,
right? It's not necessarily that you
just say, "Hey, give me a score." Right?
But the professor has a rubric.
Professor says, "Okay, well, it needed
to be three pages long. If it's not
three pages long, 100% off. It needed to
have five different sources cited. You
didn't do that. If you only cited three,
well, that's uh 20% off." Uh, you needed
a professional tone. Every time your
tone slips out of professional, uh, take
3% off your score, right? And so you can
see that the rules start building up and
you give really clear instructions on
how the how the the output should be
judged and asking your judge to explain
its reasoning is often a good way to uh
do prompt engineering for the
judge. The next is segmented. This is
why I showed those slides on prompt
decomposition. In practice, almost all
scaled workloads are multiple steps,
right? There's very very few workloads
I've ever seen that are a single prompt,
right? And what that means is you need
to evaluate each step individually. And
this actually is is uh powerful for a
number of reasons. Not the least of
which is that it's very rare for a
workload to be a single model. It's much
more appropriate for each step because
they're evaluated individually. We
evaluate which model is appropriate.
Many times as semantic router you want
to use something like Nova Micro that's
going to give you an instant response.
It's very simple and easy. It's going to
give you one, two, three. Um and so you
can you can with an evaluation framework
prove to yourself the smallest model
that's appropriate to use on each step.
Diverse is what I was mentioning
earlier. You want to cover all of your
use cases. So sometimes I'll start by
listing out what are the use cases in
scope and then make sure we have
questions applying to all of them. I
will say the hundred is a rule of thumb.
Sometimes if they're use cases that are
like edge cases we don't really care
about. I'll put in like three or four
examples for that. But the core use
cases we want a lot of examples for. And
then the last one I'll mention is
traditional. Um, and I put this in there
because there is a tendency to uh throw
the baby out with a bathwater and say,
"Hey, this is geni. We're all going to
use geni. We're going to geni
everything." You know, the output of
your my semantic router is one. I'll use
jenny to see if that one is really the
number one, right? And uh the answer is
no. There are a lot of traditional
techniques that are very very powerful.
Um obviously if the output is numeric
just just use a numeric evaluation. uh
for things like rag architecture is one
of the most common um there's many many
types of uh database accuracy
evaluations retrieval and precision and
F1 scores and all those kinds of things
for question answering um simple things
like measuring cost and latency are
still traditional tooling so I just want
to I I put that there to highlight the
fact that traditional tooling is still
very very powerful and very important uh
in the context of GI evaluations all
right I'm going to give a quick example
of what this looks like. Uh and uh just
uh visually we start with that gold
standard set. Again, this is where I
think the most important uh use of your
time is is is building this. Your whole
system is going to be pointed towards
and designed towards this gold standard
set. So if your gold standard set has a
bunch of errors, what you've done is
designed a whole system that does that
creates errors, right? Um so so invest
it's always worth time investing in
building a good gold standard set.
I will uh as a brief aside mention this
is a a terrible place to use GEI. If you
use GEI to create your gold standard
set. If the GEI set creates errors,
you've built you build a system that
generates the same errors that the GI
system has. Uh and it can lead to a lot
of problems. It can be helpful to
generate a what I would call a silver
standard set which is the GI system
taking a guess at a gold standard but it
still needs to be reviewed by a human to
confirm its accuracy. All right, we take
an input from that gold standard set,
one of those, we put it into our prompt
template, put it into our LLM in order
to generate an output. We include the
answer and the reasoning. Then we take
the the matching answer from that gold
standard input uh and we compare it with
that generated output into a judge
prompt and the judge generates a number
and the reasoning behind that number.
Um, and then we pull the category. Often
I'll I'll include the category in the
gold standard set so that um we can then
as that final step uh break things down
by category and um
and generate a summary for the right and
wrong answers uh for each
category. All right, that's it. Thank
you so much. I hope this was helpful.
Uh, please feel free to reach out with
questions and comments and enjoy your
day.